this video is going viral many of such
videos going viral of a trans man which
is to say a woman
uh complaining
that she is being misgendered and
usually when we see these videos and
conservatives play these videos all the
time we just kind of make fun of the
people and we say oh you know come on
you know yeah no one's calling you by
this fantasy
that actually wasn't my reaction maybe
it's because this is a woman who's
pretending to be a man that wasn't my
reaction first time I saw this video
being trans is so hard and so exhausted
like I I've been misgendered all
every single interaction comes
dismissed standard from the beginning
today to now just sick of it I'm sick of
correcting people who won't listen I'm
and I'm sick of people not seeing me I'm
sick I'm so sick of it and then I'm like
oh well if I went on t
this would never happen but I
I just left off to believe that trans
people exist
and to look at me and think for a split
second like oh maybe they don't want to
call the lady maybe maybe that's
so
uh uh this one is some of the videos are
funny
some of the videos with these really
over the top flamboyant people making a
big spectacle of themselves saying why
it's ma'am what do you mean I'm a six
foot four dude but you didn't call me
ma'am actually it's men and that's kind
of funny this one's not funny to me this
this woman at the end she pulls down her
shirt and she's got these gash marks
where her breasts used to be where some
lunatic quack doctor chopped off her
healthy organs and This Woman's crying
she says no they just don't they just
misgender me they won't gender me
correct and the only choice I have is to
go on testosterone and then you see the
desperation in her voice she says I
don't want to go on testosterone and of
course you just want to go on
testosterone testosterone I interviewed
Helena kirschner a d transitioner woman
to man to well woman to appearing more
like a man to recognize you she's a
woman again and she said when she was on
testosterone she became very aggressive
she she was impelled to violence and she
said thankfully I turned the violence on
myself I didn't turn the violence on
other people but I turned it on myself
she was cutting herself and all sorts of
great you can see the interviews on my
YouTube channel and so the testosterone
has obviously if you if you inject a
woman with a lot of testosterone it's
gonna have all sorts of crazy effects
and so this woman says I don't want to
go on that I don't but I just well I
want people call me a man I just want to
be commentary and so I I watch a video
like that
I think I can't laugh at that I can't
laugh at that any more than I would
laugh at a sky
[Music]
I'm sure that's terribly painful
the responsibility for that pain lies
with the fact of this Fallen World
people just have problems suffering is
part of life
and a lot of that pain
lies with the teachers who indulge this
supposed friends who indulge this
certainly the doctors who into quacks
who indulge this they are responsible
for that when you affirm people in lies
and then the people
become very angry and depressed because
the lies they have been told and
affirmed in don't correspond with
reality
the Liars bear a lot of that
responsibility
it's not the it's not the people who
told them the truth that bear that
responsibility it's the Liars who bear
that responsibility
and those Liars have a lot of power you
can't blame that that woman Joe Biden's
telling her that she's a man
but she knows she's not a man deep down
because she lives in reality
and her her imagination has to butt up
against reality as she makes it through
her day her teachers told her she was a
man I'm sure
her whole community did
I know the teachers are saying the
stuffies the teachers now are crying
when Republican
Governors and legislatures say that you
can't teach this stuff in schools that
you're not allowed to have gay porn like
actual gay transgender porn in schools
and the teachers are whining and crying
about this like this Texas teacher
living under a bubble then let me tell
you the right is trying to destroy
public education you might watch a video
like this you're like this person's not
smart at all wow no they know what
they're doing I'm not bashing all
Charter Schools but charter schools are
a place where problematic things can
happen let me share an experience from a
charter school interviewed out in Texas
where no I did not take the job I
interviewed for a school librarian
position I was really excited because I
was like okay I think I'm gonna go back
to teaching this year after having my
daughter I was told that the board hand
selects every single book that goes into
the library and you cannot put a single
book into the Library without the
board's approval so I straight up asked
can I teach a book with a gay couple in
it and they were like oh if it's not
explicit that means no that is an
example of what people like profile is
there hold on
so I didn't know what the answer to that
would be and I don't know what the
answer should be
should I guess it maybe depends on the
the age of the students but do you do
you think that in a in a third grade
classroom
students should be taught about these
Divergent Lifestyles I don't think so I
shouldn't children be taught men or men
women or women marriage is the union
between a man and a woman that's what
marriage does mean necessarily means and
always has meant and certain people live
in eccentric ways but this is not what
we're going to tell you is normal and
desirable
is it that's what education always was
until
like this year
so I don't know now maybe in
high school or something 11th or 12th
grade
you could see a book where where one
says okay well actually this is this
kind of alternative arranged men here's
this alternative Arrangement there's
this that and the other thing but
but even regardless let's say that
there's a school district that says no
we want to teach about gay relationships
in the third grade
at the very least there should be some
oversight of that at the very least that
should be up to the parents and the
community in a self-governing society
rather than just one
really passionate activist teacher right
even if you're totally in favor of
teaching kindergarteners about gay
relationships or transgenderism for that
matter what the what the teacher is
complaining about here is not what's
being censored or not being censored
because she said the the board is
allowing the the gay stuff to be taught
in schools as long as it's not
pornographic what she's complaining
about is any oversight at all and what
people on the right want to do with
public education and remember Charter
Schools like that one that I just
described are all government funded we
are paying for that school to accept
yeah it's it's not government funded
because the government is you funded
sir it's the it's the government taking
money from people and then spending that
money in the way that the people desire
at least some of the time and the people
through their elected representatives
are voting for school choice because
they don't want to be locked into these
cartels where teacher unions get to milk
the people and the people I have no say
over have the money spent or how their
kids are educated so if the schools are
failing the parents can say nope we're
pulling our kid out of there we don't
want our kid being taught
gay porn in the third grade so we're
gonna pull that t that that student out
and put them in this charter school that
we'll give our our student a shot and a
great education and this is especially
true for people who are who are middle
class and lower class
because
the wealthy people always get to send
their kids to whatever schools they want
and the upper class in the middle class
can usually homeschool if they want
but if you're making not a lot of money
and you're in a place with not a lot of
educational options
then your only ticket out school choice
the teacher says that's really awful
because it's the it's government money
no honey it's people money
and we have self-government in the
United States
and the libs always talk about power to
the people until the people don't want
to go along with their
programs we will be moving into the
member block the Nostradamus member room
segmentum we will be examining some
movies that Mr Davies insists that I
check out the rest of the show continues
now you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles kwles and check
out for two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]